welcome to this video playing gullet
galit from spain for four and a half out
of six i got against the guy and he's
deeply irritated by Knight f6 it seems
okay um can I treat ate him maybe maybe
this one that's not not bad normally
coming out of the the tango check okay
we will transposed to a bogo Indian type
of position check yeah that's a line of
the bogo that I normally don't play also
not featured in my my book project but
it is it still a playable line I have
played this for example in the german
bundesliga with me okay yeah I can't
play but should be to winning the
exchange it's still not it's still not
so easy because the position is so so
blocked it's not them not an easy win
okay g6 probably necessary night f5 is
not to move you you want to face okay
should I play be 6 cm be 695 I think I
should try to open the pollution really
okay well castles first on f4 I don't
need to react and I want to I want to
open here the sea ha for my looks
c6 rook c8 taking this kind of okay he
takes himself okay so i probably should
try to get a knight to e 609 f-86 maybe
start with Luke here and then rook night
f-86 okay okay here we go maybe even see
five and nine td4 I'm night SI hai phir
on the other hand is also one attack on
one knee for why not actually on e4 nb3
maybe the some yeah Queenie three maybe
then I can go rook be eight maybe I'm
managing to exchange my a pawn for one
of his Queen side ponds and like that
getting rid of one weakness yeah here I
can actually think of night 94 anyway
okay I can take with a look at the end
of a but still then this is one hanging
okay then this is a good movie my
original idea is 9485 taking on e4 yeah
but there's also be for hanging which
makes it additionally attractive so here
Knight takes or group takes before you
after night takes the the point is still
hanging so and not so easily protected
yes c5 was my intention here not
probably okay ah that's that's a that's
a pin hmm hmm now that's not ideal I
miss just this a bit rookie won the Sun
is a problem but maybe I can take before
I just push the porner take takes on be4
okay 1b 394 be tuned there's knight c6
though
okay maybe do this with Knight f6 coming
if he okay hmm yeah this this should be
a window right if I go let's say here
Queen trade you must trade queens now
and the knight on c3 is also looking to
be transferred to be six where it blocks
the beep horn and the text the sea for
weakness
yeah I wonder if I should return return
the pawn I'll return the exchange here
to take the form they have come on
probably the easiest bishop f1 ahead I
can take III that's quite quite
convincing I hope and b5 is not I don't
see how he defends it Bishop d7 but it's
also not not totally a tractor time
morning so even 95 here I'll take you
three year this should be good
v6 or take a drug CA attack modest this
should be should be an easy easy win
and then get the King into the game c7 I
just approached with the King and I ok 6
was a bit tougher but I think losing as
well check oopsie seven Koopa turns out
to be a really bad pre-move yeah getting
into the king and bone ending check
white resigns yeah ok basically
blundered the exchange and after that
it's a matter of of technical plane but
i thought i did a did a decent job here
c6 looks good yahoo to open up the see
file and here i get i get good positions
for my pieces on 95 was an interesting
move here also you know because this is
really to my advantage very much so as i
get this great square on d4 yeah night c
4 sir 5 directly was strong but this is
also good technically yeah this was was
very much okay also here maybe c5 was
better i am
okay see if I've directly is better yeah
of course you cannot take a c5 was
better this this should also win but it
makes things a bit more tricky yeah here
Queenie five I thought that this might
be the best but I couldn't really
calculate it to the end rookie one ah
times i'm stupid of course be 394 be 296
it's no problem I can go to aid and I'm
promoting this is also totally winning
okay but this is really a bit
complicated I think this is this was
sufficient it it should when it's not so
so quick not so this size of predator it
should win and here maybe 93 is simpler
but it's a it's a win after all okay
thanks for watching